the worst anti-semitic shooting in
American history rocks the country the
left blames President Trump and a
populist wins a shock victory in Brazil
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
well obviously an awful morning to be
doing a podcast but here we are and I
have a lot of thoughts obviously on what
happened over the weekend the worst
anti-semitic shooting in American
history taking place at the Tree of Life
synagogue in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
just awful and a lot to break down here
about the state of American politics
about the state of the country about the
state of civilization suffice it to say
the short story here is that when the
seams of Western civilization begin to
come apart anti-semitism is what crawls
through those gaps and that's exactly
what we've seen in the past few years
I'll talk more about that in just a
second first on a more uplifting note
let's talk about how you feed your dog
so dog food companies claim to use
natural ingredients but what kind of
beef or carrots can sit in a paper bag
for a year we can't eat processed food
for every meal and be our healthiest and
neither can your dog which is why you
need the farmers dog it's the company
helping dogs live long healthy lives
with nutritious fresh ready to serve dog
meals delivered directly to your door
now listen I will be honest I don't know
that much red Dawgs I don't know much
about dog food but I do know that my
bosses Doug my boss my business partners
dog Jasper
he loves this dog food not only that I
have many dog lovers who are in my
immediate family and among my friend
group and the farmers dog is great for
them and here's how it works
clever marketing has convinced Americans
to feed unhealthy kibble and can mush
the farmers dog is different the farmers
dog is the company that helps those dogs
by giving them nutritious fresh ready to
serve dog meals delivered directly to
your door you complete a short online
quiz of that developed plan is created
just for your dog food arrives at your
door in pre-portion package is ready to
open and pour it's easy it looks and
smells like real food because it is real
food just ask the chief executive dog my
real boss over at the daily wire Jasper
he voraciously gives his paw prints of
approval indeed oh we got a dog that is
a dog that really likes that food start
feeding your dog better today try a week
for free at the farmers dog calm slash
Ben plus you get free shipping again get
your first week for free at the farmers
dog calm slash Ben the farmers dog.com
slash Ben go check it out right now
you take that quiz and then the vet
develop plan is created just for your
dog and all this stuff arrives free at
your door the farmers dog calm slash Ben
the product is not free the shipping is
free go check it out right now the
farmers dog calm
you bet so you're gonna want a piece of
it or your dog is in any case so go
check that out right now all right so
let's talk about this tree of life
shooting so over the weekend obviously
the worst and cementec shooting attack
in the history of the United States 11
people murdered in a synagogue during
what we call a brief meal ah a bris
which is where an 8 day old boy is
circumsized and the baby naming ceremony
takes place at that point this was a
conservative synagogue not a politically
conservative synagogue a religiously
conservative synagogue in Judaism in
American Judaism anyway
there are several branches of Judaism
I'm an Orthodox Jew which means deeply
observant keep Sabbath don't drive on
Sabbath keep kosher
there's conservative judaism which is
sort of less orthodox people drive on
sabbath they sort of keep a form of
sabbath they don't keep the full kosher
but they have certain respect for torah
laws in any case this conservative
synagogue didn't have much security and
in anti-semitic white supremacist but i
repeat myself walked into the synagogue
armed with an ar-15 and proceeded to
shoot up the bris mila he was screaming
at the time all jews must die so
obviously a subtle fella so why does
this matter first of all i think that we
need to get something off the table
right away when an anti-semitic attack
occurs you generally don't need to
bother blaming particular politicians
anti-semitism is literally as old as the
jewish people literally as old as the
jewish people now there are politicians
in the past who have called for
anti-semitism there are politicians in
the past who have actively called for
the murder of Jews
I'm not saying a lot of those on today's
American scene there are a lot of
politicians on today's American scene
who hobnob with anti-semites who make
common cause with anti-semites we'll get
to all of that in just a second but
folks who are blaming the left or the
right for the answers emetic shooting
that happened yesterday white
supremacism and anti-semitic attacks on
Jews have existed for decades in this
country long before anything that is
going on in today's politics and that's
not to downplay what's happening in
today's politics that's what the rest of
the show is going to be about but let's
just be clear about this when it comes
to attacks on Jews there is nothing new
Under the Sun legitimately nothing new
Under the Sun I don't know a single Jew
seriously a single Jew who is not one
degree removed from a violent attack on
a Jew and that's not to say that
America's violent country for Jews it is
not America is the safest country in
world history for Jews America is an
incredible place
Jews but because the Jewish population
is so small and because so many Jews
know each other and because the Jews
sort of consider themselves an extended
family just as Christians consider
themselves an extended religious family
it's difficult not to feel it deeply
obviously when when an attack like this
takes place the history of the Jewish
people is filled with fractious division
but history has treated the Jews is a
closely bound unit Jewish identity isn't
really a choice it's a reality modernity
has obscured this for a lot of Jews but
the fact is that all Jews are in the
same boat when it comes to anti-semites
like this and as I say every Jew is one
degree removed from some level of
anti-semitic violence and I live in the
Los Angeles community I'm probably if
not the most prominent Orthodox Jew in
the country the most prominent Orthodox
Jew wearing a yarmulke in the country I
think would be fair to say I walk around
in public with a yarmulke that's how
safe I think this country is I live in a
city with some nine hundred thousand
Jews Los Angeles has nine hundred
thousand Jews living in the city still
anti-semitic attacks have occurred in
the LA Jewish community since I was a
child in 1991 a synagogue just down the
block from me was firebombed in 1999 a
white supremacist drove past the high
school that I would attend a year later
checked it out and then proceeded to
drive over to the West Valley JCC and
shoot it up in 2002 a radical Muslim
terrorist walked into the ll counter at
LAX and shot up the ll counter killing a
member of my community when I attended
the issue of the University High School
of Los Angeles we had bomb scares bomb
threats maybe over three months we'd
have to evacuate the school so
anti-semitism particularly from white
supremacists is nothing new here so this
brings us to the bigger question the
this brings us to the bigger question
and that is why this thing happened
right now now I'm not going to mention
the name of the shooter because I don't
mention the name of terrorists or mass
shooters on the program I don't want to
give them any sort of glory this mass
shooter used a little-known social
network to spew hatred toward Jews he
called them the children of Satan as he
showed off his family of firearms he now
faces the death penalty after unleashing
the guns on worshippers at the Tree of
Life synagogue he was particularly upset
about a non-jewish nonprofit providing
aid to refugees the Jewish nonprofit is
is called highest and he tweeted highest
lights to bring in vain
they kill our people I can't sit by and
watch my people get slaughtered screw
your optics I'm going in that was the
last tweet that he sent before he went
and murdered a bunch of Jews most of
them over the age of 50 including a
Holocaust survivor he also had a
particular dislike for President Trump
he dismissed President Trump as a
globalist rather than at a nationalist
he said there is no Magda as long as
there is a infestation I'm gonna
use the word here because I think it's
imperative to know the language that
these these monsters use these evil evil
people
so the media's take on all of this has I
think been quite simplistic and foolish
they have of course suggested that
President Trump is responsible for
everything President Trump is
responsible for the shooting
specifically because President Trump in
2016 2017 Winton nodded at the alt right
now I was highly critical of President
Trump for doing that I am highly
critical of President Trump for doing
that I was the number-one target of
alt-right anti-semitism online in 2016
with a bullet it was not close 40% of
all anti-semitic tweets by the alt-right
in 2016 were directed at me personally
okay so I am well-acquainted with the
folks that President Trump Whittington
nodded at this guy was not all right he
was a white supremacist there is a
slight difference he is not a member of
the modern alt-right movement which is
disgusting and evil and anti-semitic and
of itself but he is a white supremacist
with with a longer standing past because
this is a complex topic I'm gonna try to
parse this I'm gonna try to parse this
because a bunch of things can be true
all at once number one just as I said
last week with regard to the attempted
bombings against democratic targets just
as I said then you cannot connect a
politician's rhetoric to a violent
action unless the politician actually
calls for the violent action President
Trump has engaged in nothing even
remotely approaching incitement against
Jews
no one can aim a single comment that
he's ever made that looks like
incitement against Jews in fact this
President of the United States has been
extraordinarily pro-israel and Pro
Jewish the president's comments in
response to this particular anti-semitic
attack were far stronger than his
predecessors responses to similar
anti-semitic attacks for example here's
what the President of the United States
had to say in the after this is clip 15
this is what the president had to say in
the aftermath of the attack the scourge
of anti-semitism cannot be ignored
not be tolerated and it cannot be
allowed to continue we can't allow it to
continue it must be confronted and
condemned everywhere it rears its very
ugly head we must stand with our Jewish
brothers and sisters to defeat
anti-semitism and vanquish the forces of
hate that's what it is okay so his his
statements that anti-semitism must be
eradicated it was a far stronger
statement than Barack Obama's tweet so
here's what Barack Obama tweeted and I
want to show you the contrast between
this because again if we're going to
talk about standing with the Jews then
we have to talk about whose response to
this attack was actually a better
president Trump's about it was better
than Obama's here was Obama's response
on Twitter we grieve for the Americans
murdered in Pittsburgh all of us have to
fight the rise of anti-semitism and
hateful rhetoric against those who look
love or pray differently and we have to
stop making it so easy for those who
want to harm the innocent to get their
hands on a gun president Trump took on
anti-semitism point-blank
he said anti-semitism is evil and it
must be eradicated he didn't try to
liken it to hatred against any other
group he didn't try to make it about gun
control Barack Obama did both of those
things the left has a tendency to
obscure anti-semitism with the broad
brush of bigotry simply saying that
anti-semitism is like any other hatred
it is not like any other hatred every
hatred has its own diagnosis every
hatred has its own symptoms anti black
racism is not the same as anti-white
racism anti black racism is not the same
thing as anti-semitism anti LGBT
homophobia is not the same thing as
anti-semitism Barack Obama simply wants
to push a progressive agenda and so he
lumps in anti-semitism with all other
forms of hatred that is inaccurate and
it is untrue and it does have some
consequences when it comes to policy now
let's go through some of the elements
here that I think are important first of
all as I say president Trump in 2016
2017 did wink and not at the outright
okay again I've said this a thousand
times I've wrote editorials about it I
was extraordinarily vocal about it from
his unwillingness to condemn David Duke
on CNN his unwillingness to condemn
alt-right to tax on Julia Joffe the GQ
journalist we'll get to in a second to
bringing on Steve Bannon who called
himself the progenitor of a website that
was that became a gathering place for
the alt-right president Trump pointa
nodded at this I know this because I
became the target of the alt-right
Trump statements in the
for math of Charlottesville provided
Aiden comforts white-supremacist I don't
see any way around that but Trump is not
a white supremacist and he is not an
anti-semite he has a pathological
aversion to criticizing anyone who says
anything nice about him point number two
there's a bunch of things that are true
at the same time and if you want to
understand what's going on we need to
recognize this point number two white
supremacism is not outright Magda they
are not the same category of people
white supremacists long predated
President Trump they're not a new
development those people were going to
shoot Jews regardless of what anybody
had to say because they have been
shooting Jews since long before I was
born in 1999 as I mentioned a white
supremacist shot up our local JCC that
same year six Orthodox Jews were shot in
Chicago along with a black man in
several Asians by a white supremacist
this sort of stuff has been happening
for a very long time it has nothing to
do with President Trump third President
Trump has separated from the alt-right
in dramatic ways hey to say the
President Trump is still associated with
the alt-right is to be ignorant of
president Trump's administration or what
he has done the alt-right is enraged
with him if you go look at Richard
Spencer if you go look at some of the
other members of the alt-right they're
angry at him they believe that he has
been hijacked by the globalists okay the
same way that this shooter thought that
President Trump was standing up too much
for the
okay so that is the way that is just a
basic truth president Trump has been
extraordinarily Pro Jewish and
pro-israel in his actual presidency that
is a basic foundational truth and if you
failed to acknowledge it you are lying
by omission hey in a second I'm gonna
get to a few more points we have to keep
in mind then we'll get to the media's
response which again I think is
simplistic despicable and partisan we'll
get to all of that in just one second
first let's talk about your back of
comfort so I can't say enough about our
next sponsor the teeter inversion table
the teeter inversion table allows you to
use gravity and your own bodyweight to
decompress your spine relieve pressure
on your discs and surrounding nerves
decompressing on the teeter inversion
table for a few minutes a day is a great
addition to your daily routine I work
out a lot and that means that I get
lower back pain on a fairly frequent
basis what I do is I climb on that
teeter inversion table and I promise you
by the end of it by the end of my little
session on the teeter inversion table
I'm feeling a lot better I feel much
better it decompresses my spine it's
good for my shoulders I've done my
homework it is the best inversion table
on the market over three million people
have put their trust in teeter and for
good reason in fact my training partner
my my personal trainer he's a guy with
back problems he's been using the teeter
inversion table as well he loves it
they're offering a great deal just for
my listeners for a limited time you can
get the brand-new 2019 Teeter fits fine
inversion table model with bonus
accessories and a free pair of gravity
boots so you can invert at home or take
the boots with you to the gym teeter
inversion tables have thousands of
reviews on amazon.com they are rated at
4.6 stars and with this deal you will
get 150 bucks off when you go to teeter
calm /ban also you get free shipping
free return 60 day money-back guarantee
so you're not losing anything remember
you can only get those twenty the new
2019 teeter Fit spine inversion table
plus a free pair of gravity boots by
going to teeter calm / Ben that's te e
ter dot-com / Ben go check it out right
now teeter com / Ben okay a few more
points that we have to keep in mind with
regard to the shooting in Pennsylvania
and what it has to do with President
Trump which is to say very little
president Trump's I say has separated
from the alt-right in dramatic ways so
the first three points that I've made
here President Trump did wink and nod at
the alt-right for two years to white
supremacism not the same as alt-right
Magga three president Trump has
separated from the alt-right in dramatic
ways and they are pissed at him over it
okay that is true of this shooter - who
is anti Trump forth if we're going to
talk about how flirting with
anti-semites and anti-semitic rhetoric
and this making things less safe for
Jews then let's actually talk about that
who do you think has made the world less
safe for Jews president Trump and is
winking and nodding at the all right or
the left which mainstream's Louis
Farrakhan which mainstream's Linda
Sarsour
which mainstream's the BDS movement
which mainstream's
wildly anti-israel and anti-semitic
policies which one do you think is more
damaging to Jews all across the world
and in the United States which ones you
think is leading to more mainstream
anti-semitism do you think it's the
party that might have removed Jerusalem
tried to remove Jerusalem in 2012 from
their platform or is it the party that
moved the US Embassy to Jerusalem and
Israel do you think that it's the party
standing up for religious freedom or do
you think that it's the party looking to
obliterate a religious freedom in the
name of so-called anti-discrimination do
you think that it's the party that
mainlines keith Ellison and tries to
make him head of the DNC
after he refuses and spends years
backing Louis Farrakhan or do you think
that it might be the party that opposes
that mainstream members of the
Democratic Party routinely hobnob with
anti-semites not just hobnob with them
agree with them
this is to run the European left as well
folks like Jeremy Corbyn in Britain
expressing their sympathy for what
happened in Pittsburgh go F yourself
dude no one is interested in what Hamas
supporter has to say about Jews being
shot in a synagogue in in Pittsburgh see
for the Jewish community really for Jews
who really care about being Jewish there
is not a whit of difference between a
Jew being murdered for being a Jew in
Jerusalem a Jew being murdered for being
Jewish in France and we're drooping
murder for being Jewish in Pittsburgh
it's all of a piece and for folks on the
Left who suggest that the death of a Jew
in Jerusalem is different than the death
of a Jew in Pittsburgh for anti-semitic
reasons those people are part of the
problem is if we're going to talk about
anti-semitic rhetoric and who's to blame
for a rise in Jewish deaths the world
over a rise in hate crimes the world
over
then let's actually talk about I don't
think the left wants to talk about that
I think what they want is partisan
hackery
little more on this in just a second
let's be clear about this
when President Trump tried to wink and
nod at the alt-right he was taking a
fringe group a fringe group that was non
associated with the conservative
movement and he was winking and nodding
at them for political purposes and then
he tossed them out on their ear which is
why they're angry with him the
mainstream Democratic Party the
mainstream Democratic Party and the left
in this country have decided that it is
perfectly fine to hobnob with people who
support anti-semitic terrorism they've
decided that's okay I'm not blaming
those folks for what happened in
Pittsburgh that's not their fault either
but if we're gonna talk about rhetoric
and its impact on anti-jewish sentiment
the world over I'm gonna go with the
folks who every time there's war in the
Gaza Strip suggests that Jews the world
over are to blame or suggest that Israel
is to blame for defending itself or
suggest that when Jews are attacked in a
kosher supermarket in France but that it
that's a random attack well if we're
gonna condemn er a trick let's condemn
rhetoric I'm happy to separate rhetoric
from violence I'm happy to do that on
all sides but if we're gonna talk
rhetoric you have to condemn rhetoric
when it happens where it happens and
from whom it comes okay i condemned
President Trump when he was candidate
Trump doing this nonsense with the all
right I did it over and over and over
I've done the same thing with folks on
the Left I don't see anyone on the left
doing the same thing to focus on the
left I see them only doing it to folks
on the right for partisan political
reasons that's all I'm seeing I'm seeing
a bunch of people who don't give a good
damn when a Jew gets killed in Jerusalem
popping out of the woodwork to say that
the right
is responsible for what just happened in
Pittsburgh all the while championing in
Iran zeal that will lead to the
annihilation of millions of people if
the Iranians have their way if that is
partisanship that is disgusting
partisanship and I will show you that
sort of partisanship in just a second
because that's the fifth point here okay
we're actually going to talk about
policy let's separate rhetoric and
policy for just a second okay well again
I'm for the 1000th time when
anti-semitic rhetoric or rhetoric that
tut-tut anti-semitism takes place I will
condemn it loudly and strongly as I have
you can go back and listen to the show
I've done it every step of the way
against people on all sides I don't care
I'll keep doing it because it's the
right thing to do well do the same thing
with racist rhetoric I'm happy to do it
on every side Kevin now let's talk about
policy and which policy is getting Jews
killed if you're going to talk about
policies that lead to Jews dying named
president Trump's policy if the Obama
administration lied to the American
people and promoted in Iran ziyal that
gave the mullahs the clear pathway to a
nuclear weapon
president Trump not only moved the
embassy to Jerusalem he also cut off aid
to the anti-semantic openly anti-semitic
terror supporting Palestinian Authority
the Obama administration tried to make
Israel make concessions to those
terrorists the Obama administration in
the middle of the Gaza war in 2014
threatened to cut off military supplies
to the Israelis the Obama administration
was just blatantly not only anti-israel
not only blatantly anti-israel but from
a promotional of a wing of progressive
Jews for whom progressivism came first
and Judaism came second so if you're
gonna talk about policy that led to dead
Jews forget the forget the location then
you actually have to talk about but I'm
not going to talk about any of that
stuff obviously we're not going to talk
about any of that stuff so now let's
talk about how the media actually
responded to this because it's while
it's just tremendously dishonest so
let's start with a media story that came
courtesy I'm sorry this is all this is
deeply upsetting it's deeply upsetting
because we should all be on the same
side when it comes to anti-semitism I
think that we probably all would be on
the same side when it comes to
anti-semitism but nobody is actually
willing to call out anti-semitism when
and where
it exists on any side unless they are
busy defending their own political side
and their own political hide is
disgusting and the media are complicit
in this the Maggie Haberman a reporter
for whom I generally have respect at the
New York Times she tweeted out today
letter to President Trump from
Pittsburgh Jewish leaders and this is a
headline that was repeated by a variety
of media groups the Washington Post he
is not welcome here
thousands support Pittsburgh Jewish
leaders calling on Trump to denounce
white nationalism the hill progressive
Jewish leaders tell Trump he's not
welcome in Pittsburgh until he denounced
his white nationalism Newsweek Jewish
group says Donald Trump not welcome in
Pittsburgh until he is ready to fully
denounce white nationalism okay now you
would think this sounds like Jewish
leaders in Pittsburgh tell President
Trump not to show up and now what it
sounds like the headline says after all
I'm gonna tell you the whole story in
just one second cuz it turns out the
media are lying to you it turns out the
media are lying to you because they're
more interested in getting President
Trump than in actually fighting
anti-semitism or unifying against
anti-semitism it seems to me when the
presidents of the United States comes
out openly condemns anti-semitism wants
to visit Pittsburgh is probably going to
put in place new measures to fight
anti-semitism maybe we all can be on the
same side but apparently not apparently
not I'll explain first let's talk about
how you can save money on stamps so
these days can get pretty much anything
on demand you can get our podcast on
demand listen whenever you want when
it's convenient for you why are you
still taking trips to the post office to
mail letters and packages when you could
sit at your desk and do the same thing
with stamps calm you can access all the
amazing services of the post office
directly from your desk 24/7 when it is
convenient for you buy and print
official US postage for any letter any
package using your own computer and
printer the mail carrier picks it up
just click print mail you're done we use
it here at Daily wire you can print the
postage directly out onto the envelope
onto a piece of paper that you tape to
the envelope onto a sticker and you are
good to go
Sam's comb is fantastic it saves us time
and it saves us money right now use
promo code Shapiro for a special offer
including up to 55 bucks of free postage
a digital scale and a four week trial
don't wait go to stamps calm before you
do anything else click on the radio
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Shapiro that stamps comm
enter promo code Shapiro right now again
stamps comm promo code Shapiro it is the
easiest and best way for you to get your
stamps you don't have to go to the post
office you can just sit there and get it
done
stamps calm use that promo code
Shapiro again stamps.com promo code
Shapiro okay so what isn't what are the
media not telling you about the Jewish
leaders who supposedly said that
President Trump shouldn't show up there
from a group called bend the arc hey the
bend the arc wrote a letter stating for
the past three years your words and your
policies have emboldened a growing white
nationalist movement you yourself call
the murderer evil but yesterday's
violence is the direct culmination of
your influence president Trump you are
not welcome in Pittsburgh until you
fully denounce white nationalism our
Jewish community is not the only group
you have targeted you have deliberately
undermined the safety of people of color
Muslims LGBTQ people and people with
disabilities yesterday's massacre is not
the first act of terror you incited okay
so who the hell is this group who has
been the Ark okay the group is a leftist
political action group self stated with
the Jewish label their stated mission is
quote rising up in solidarity with
everyone threatened by the Trump agenda
to fight for the soul of our nation
their missions include the election of
quote progressive champions and the
implementation of progressive
legislation and policies like criminal
justice reform and economic equity who
runs bend the arc it was founded by
Alexander Soros George Soros his son
when he started the PAC Politico noted
Soros who formed his own foundation in
2012 to promote social justice and human
rights has given 1.2 million dollars to
Democratic candidates and groups in the
last three decades is a democratic
political action committee and oppressed
treated it as those a bunch of rabbis
well-respected in the Jewish community
who came out and told Trump not to show
up in Pittsburgh that is a lie the
director of bend the ark originally was
a guy at he was a guy named hotter
Susskind he was a former head staffer at
J Street an anti-semitic anti-israel BDS
group hey that's the group that's
condemning President Trump the media ran
the headline thousands support
Pittsburgh Jewish leaders calling on
Trump to denounce white nationalism that
is the headline from The Washington Post
that is a blatant absolute outright lie
it is an outright lie you know how I
know it's an outright lie because here
is a clip of the rabbi at the Tree of
Life synagogue that was just shot up on
national television being asked whether
President Trump was welcome in
Pittsburgh president Trump has talked
about coming to Pittsburgh and coming to
your synagogue in the aftermath of this
do you want him to come the Rebbe the
President of the United States is always
welcome I'm a citizen he's my president
he's certainly welcome and just how
dishonest is that the actual rabbi the
synagogue says he's welcome come to my
synagogue a bunch of anti I mean these
folks are anti Israeli a bunch of a
bunch of people on the radical left say
that they don't like President Trump and
suddenly suddenly it's Jewish leaders
all over Pittsburgh calling for this
just deep and abiding dishonesty abiding
dishonesty and this of course prompted
President Trump to get himself in
trouble again because President Trump
cannot help but step on a rake every
five seconds the president tweets out in
response to the media stuff like this
there is great anger in our country
caused in part by inaccurate and even
fraudulent reporting of the news the
fake news media the true enemy of the
people must stop the open and obvious
hostility and report the news accurately
and fairly that will do much to put out
the flame I agree with President Trump
that the media are doing a terrible job
in there lying about him and lying about
the situation but if he doesn't stop at
this enemy of the people crap he
undermines everything that he is saying
the press are not the enemy of the
people
the press are politically biased hacks
there is a difference calling on the
enemy that people only raises the
temperature in a time when it doesn't
need to be raised but he's not wrong the
media are out to get him
and he is not wrong that the media have
decided that no matter what the question
was the answer is it's Trump's fault
you're so funny on the left it became a
meme when President Obama was president
that when when something went wrong
everybody say blame Obama Obama even
joked about it there's no question that
for the left it doesn't matter what the
question is why is the why did the
butter get spoiled why is the fridge
broken why did I get in a car crash the
answer is President Trump here is the
Washington Post headline the day after
the shooting in Pittsburgh hey this is
uh this is this yeah there we go alright
the headline was eleven killed in
shooting at Pittsburgh synagogue and
then underneath that headline it says
Trump allies set the tone for violence
they denounced critics say really that's
where we're going now Trump allies set
the tone for violence they announced
critics say well that's that's a fun way
to do journalism
critics say see when I have an opinion I
just say it when the Washington Post has
an opinion they just say critics say how
convenient
how convenient and then you have Julia
Jaffe so Julia Jaffe is a so-called
journalist Tajik you now she is
to be mad at Trump back in 2015-2016 she
wrote a piece for GQ about Melania Trump
wasn't very nice and a bunch of alt
writers attacked her in anti-semitic
fashion president Trump was asked about
it he didn't condemn it that was gross
that was stupid and that was wrong I
said so at the time go back and listen
to the tape okay but Julia Jaffe has
gone off her rocker so here is what she
tweeted to all the well-meaning Gentiles
telling me what to think and not both in
and not go think about the synagogue
shooting today kindly shut up today's
our day to be quiet no everyone is
entitled to their opinion the question
is whether that opinion is good or not
like for example Julia Jeffy's Jew her
opinion sucks right here is her hers her
second take on this a word to my fellow
American Jews the president makes this
possible here where you live
I hope the embassy move over there where
you don't live was worth it so she's now
accusing Jews in the United States who
voted for President Trump or support
President Trump now of dual loyalty they
care about Jews in Israel but not Jews
in America because the president is
getting Jews killed in America while
he's being pro-israel except for the
fact that this shooter specifically
hated President Trump and except for the
fact that you don't get to blame Jews
for how they vote on Jews getting killed
how about blaming the victims now no hi
anybody at the synagogue voted maybe
they voted for Trump
maybe they didn't it doesn't matter you
don't get to blame people for the death
of other people when they have no
connection to the death of other people
but this is what the left has decided to
do they've decided that every bad thing
that happens in the country from an evil
person has to be the result of President
Trump's rhetoric now again I condemned
President Trump when it came to the
alt-right stuff but you can't show me
the connection that is solid between
what happened at the Pittsburgh
synagogue and president Trump's all
right stuff number one and number two if
we're gonna talk about rhetoric that
leads to violence against Jews that's
gonna open a whole can of worms I don't
think the left once opened and Matt
Iglesias who is just an idiot I mean
he's he's Ralph he's Ralphie from from
The Simpsons over at over at Vox you
tweeted out about Steve Scalise Steve
Scalise said this morning's attack is a
reminder that anti-semitism and other
forms of bigotry still persist in our
society and must be confronted and
combatted at every turn and Glacia has
tweeted
David Duke without the baggage so now
every Republican is responsible for a
white nationalist shooting up a
synagogue hey I'm an
Orthodox Jew this is a lie it is a lie I
go to synagogue way more than any of the
people who I've quoted so far on the
show okay and not only that I'm seeing
an argument being made we'll get to this
in a second the gun control argument
that is being made by folks on the left
in response to all of this you know my
response to all of this is I'm going to
start carrying a gun to shul hey that's
my response to all of this my response
is Jews should be armed people in
synagogues should be armed hey you know
why because white nationalists are not
going to give up their guns evil people
don't give up their guns so that means I
want more people at my shul armed I want
more security guards at my show we'll
get to all of that in just a second
sorry it's an angry show today but
there's there's no way around it really
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first let's talk about how you
can save a little bit of money so these
days it's obviously difficult to get
people to agree on practically anything
but there's one thing we can all agree
on saving money you can save them the
cash and the way to do that is by going
to honey honey is a free shopping tool
that automatically searches the internet
for the best promo codes every time you
buy something online
honey believes everyone deserves the
best prices possible on all the things
they love that's why it works on all
your favourite sites like Amazon or Ebay
or j.crew Walmart Best Buy Groupon honey
has already saved listeners of this show
an average of 26 bucks 34 cents I use
honey every time I use amazon.com and I
use Amazon that calm an awful lot they
make all my products cheaper my wife and
I recently bought a pressure cooker and
we got it off of Amazon and honey made
it significantly cheaper honey has 10
million members they have over a hundred
thousand five star reviews you can save
on pretty much anything using honey it's
the money saving shopping tool everyone
can agree on get honey for free at join
honey calm /ban that's join honey calm /
menus that slash men so they know we
sent you honey is the easiest way to
save money while shopping online
that's honey join honey calm / pen once
more join honey calm / better okay so I
have a lot more to get to really a lot
more to get to you today but you're
going to have to go over to daily we're
calm and subscribe for $9.99 a month you
can get a subscription to the daily wire
when you do you get the rest of this
show live you get the rest of Andrew
Clavin show live you get the rest of
Michael moles is show live plus plus
you'll be able to get all sorts of other
goodies like for example don't miss
Andrew clavin's next chapter of another
kingdom performed by Michael moles today
subscribers get exclusive access to
episode 5 titled
nightmare feast if you're not a
subscriber you won't be able to watch
new episodes of season 2 until Friday so
what are you waiting for head on over to
daily wire.com subscribe to watch the
first and second seasons of another
Kingdom coming up on Tuesday November
6th don't miss our next episode of daily
we're backstage either you can ask us
questions if you're a subscriber
it's our election edition it's God King
Jeremy boring me Andrew Clavin the
horrible Michael Noel's Alicia Krauss
we'll all be there covering the latest
election news so we'll be bringing you
the results as they come in as always
only daily where subscribers got to ask
the questions so make sure that you go
and subscribe today go check it out
right now
all right so make sure that you
subscribe to get the rest of today's
show live we got a lot to talk about and
be part of the mailbag later this week
we always have goodies coming up also
make sure that you subscribe over at
iTunes or over at YouTube when you do
you get access to our Sunday special
this week we're having on Tucker Carlson
correct
so Tucker's gonna be stopping by it
should be awesome you're gonna want to
be a part of that go check it out right
now we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so as I say members of the Democratic
Left have decided that when an
anti-semitic shooting takes place in
Pittsburgh that has nothing to do with
President Trump it's obviously president
Trump's fault and they've continued with
this narrative Franklin for who is a
columnist over at the Atlantic he wrote
a full column basically on this idea
that members of the Jewish community who
support Republicans are responsible he
tweeted the organized shunning of
Sheldon Adelson Jared Kushner and other
Jewish enablers is a matter of
protecting the security of the community
Sony got this straight being mean to
Jared Kushner is now going to prevent
shootings at synagogues mm-hmm being
mean to Sheldon Adelson one of the great
supporters of Israel in the United
States and one of the great supporters
of Jewish programs like birthright in
the United States that is somehow going
to make juice safer in the United States
if you shun me because according to for
I'm one of the enablers you shun me shun
Dennis Prager you shouldn't any other
Jew who happens to be on the right this
is protecting the security of the
community really is that what this is so
if you elect Barack Obama or if you
elect Keith Ellison or if you elect a
bunch of Democrats who openly hobnob
with Linda Sarsour
then that makes Jews safer but if you
shun the most pro-israel president in
American history and any Jew who
supports that president even while
condemning his rhetoric then you are
somehow making the Jewish community
safer I'm sorry this is disgusting stuff
it's disgusting stuff and then you get
folks like Adam Schiff again Democrat
from California he says president Trump
set the tone of hatred this is the easy
argument always again this is just an
extension of the argument made last week
about the bombing attempts against
democratic members and that rhetoric is
is what causes violence I don't remember
any of these conversations happening on
mainstream television after Bernie
Sanders supporters shot up a bunch of
Congress people on a congressional
baseball field they don't remember these
conversations happening for longer than
two days who's out of the headlines
immediately now we're going to get
nothing but this for months because this
was always let's be clear about
something
this was always going to be the
Democratic narrative and it almost has
nothing to do with President Trump now
president Trump plays right into the
heart of it because he can't shut his
face but this has almost nothing to do
with President Trump if this happened
under President Bush you get the same
crap if this happened under President
Romney you'd get the same crap it would
not matter people on the Left tried to
suggest that I was responsible for
bombing attempts last week there are
folks on the Left who tried to suggest
that I bore responsibility for it
happened in Pittsburgh okay this is
insane this is insane and you can you
can separate out all these issues you
can condemn bad rhetoric when you see it
on any side without doing this routine
this partisan hack job where Adam Schiff
is suddenly the great arbiter of decent
rhetoric in the middle of a terrible
political time no one sets the tone more
than president United States and the
tone that he sets is one of division
often one of hatred sometimes one of
incitement of violence against
journalists and there's no escaping our
collective responsibility but there's no
escaping the tone that he sets for the
country okay it's just again I agree
that President Trump should set a better
tone for the country to blame president
Trump's tone for everything that has
happened here 2/4 is insane can the tone
of the country was already off the rails
by 2012 it's been years since we've had
a decent political conversation in this
country it's been a very very long time
blamed Trump all you want pretend that
this is all about Trump ignore your own
complicity in the breakdown of our
political culture but let's not pretend
that the world started spinning when
president from suddenly entered the
political spin scene and let's stop
pretending that the Democratic Party has
clean hands when it comes to association
with anti-semites now one of the one of
the more scurrilous attacks on Trump and
folks on the right is the suggestion
that if you're a critical of George
Soros who are somehow anti-semitic so
there's been a big narrative put out by
folks on the Left that George Soros who
is a lead Democratic donor that if you
criticize George Soros by suggesting
that he gives a lot of money to cause as
their nefarious then this means that you
are somehow anti-semitic
now you can attack George Soros and an
anti-semitic way you can suggest that
he's part of a Jewish cabal attempting
to run the country but it seems to me
that the criticism of George Soros on
the right on the mainstream right has
been no more market than the criticism
of Sheldon Adelson on the left it seems
to me that the criticism of George Soros
is very much akin to the criticism of
the Koch brothers on the left and yet
the idea now is that we are going to
spin every critique of George Soros into
this is all about George Soros as Jewish
heritage which is nonsense
hey but again CNN is pushing this say
you're blaming them are you blaming them
I'm
blaming them for putting that guest on
the air and not you know correcting him
in real-time and I so far as I know 12
hours later doing nothing about it my
blaming honestly at this level after we
have tucker carlson and laura ingraham
have known all these people in the past
right on TV every night I'm blaming the
management of Fox and the investors in
fact what he's talking about here
there's a fox business guest who said
that the caravan had something to do
with the Soros the Soros run State
Department or something like that
and now is that anti-semitic no it may
be idiotic but it's not anti-semitic
okay George Soros doesn't run the State
Department but the idea that going after
George Soros as a nefarious force in
American politics is somehow inherently
anti-semitic is ridiculous in the same
way as suggesting that going after
Sheldon Adelson is inherently
anti-semitic when he's a major donor to
the Republican Party the Democrats are
looking for a narrative they found a
convenient narrative and so this is what
they're going to do and again I am NOT
going to pretend I'm not going to
pretend that the left has clean hands
when it comes to fighting anti-semitism
and they certainly do not the women's
March tweeted out their sympathy for all
of this and the twins it's created
sympathy they said we are turning our
grief to action with with at Jewish
action to send a clear message that
these anti-semitic and xenophobic
attacks can never happen again if you're
not in DC tune in around 3:00 p.m. to
our Facebook page to watch and share the
live stream the women's March includes
two head women who associate openly and
defend Louis Farrakhan I am NOT
interested in your help ladies if you if
you refuse to denounce the anti-semitism
in your own midst I am NOT interested
there's a solidarity event in New York
City al Sharpton showed up at the
solidarity event you've got to be
kidding me
is there anything more partisan and
hackish than this I haven't seen
anything recently Marcia Blackburn did a
unity event leftist came and they
disrupted a unity event in anti-semitism
anti anti anti Semitism unity event with
Marcia Blackburn the 10th to the
Tennessee senatorial candidate left his
showed up to scream adder
[Applause]
within the last few hours protesters
interrupted a rally for Congress
Moo Marcia black she hosted Senator
Lindsey Graham and West Nashville at Ray
Stevens cabaret our crew at the event
saw four people taken out and a police
sergeant told just three genius genius
okay now the final narrative the left is
trying to try it out so they've tried
out in a few narratives one is that it
was Trump's fault - as it was Jews who
support from his fault is all very
convenient isn't it very convenient how
you just got to say all the things you
say about people you hate normally
except now you get to blame them for
murder okay all of us it all the while
supporting a party that routinely
undermines Israel and associates with
open anti-semites there are very
convenient okay the final narrative that
is put forward is the narrative of gun
control so people are very angry because
Trump right after the attacks he said
that synagogues need better security
here was president Trump's immediate
response to the attacks
you take a look if they had protection
inside the results would have been far
better this is a dispute that will
always exist I suspect but if they had
some kind of a protection inside the
temple maybe it could have been a very
much different situation hey he is not
wrong I know he got a lot of flack for
this because he's not talking about
anti-semitism right there not only is he
not wrong this has been known wide
widely known in the Jewish community for
legitimately decades for decades in in
France if you go to France and you go to
a Jewish institution every Jewish
institution in France has a gated yard
every single one if you go to any place
in Europe that is a synagogue the
security there is heavy the security at
my synagogue is heavy
we have probably 15 synagogues in my
immediate area the security at all of
them is heavy
if the synagogue were out with Bar
Mitzvah now has a security fence all the
way around it and does not leave the
door unlocked is that sad yes is it
reality also yes when I pick a school
for my children a Jewish day school for
my children they have to fulfill certain
philosophical commitments obviously but
within that band there a bunch of
schools in the area that do that the
very first thing that I look at the
first thing I ask about is the security
consideration at those schools really
and it's been this way for Italy to
pretend this at this started with Trump
is just nonsense it's not true okay in
2001 I remember on September 11th 2001
my
and I were actually set to go golfing
that morning and we drove up to a a
school where my sisters were going and
we drove up and they didn't really have
security that wasn't a thing back in
2001 so much and they asked if we could
just stand outside so we were the extra
security that day on 9/11 okay with
hundred nine irons hey that very soon
ended right after 9/11 they up security
significantly and that was true for
every Jewish institution that I knew
about this is true for virtually every
Jewish institution in the United States
anti-semitism is very real violence is
very real now one of the reasons that I
suspect that wasn't additional security
at this conservative synagogue is
because conservative and reform
synagogues typically don't have quite
the same security as Orthodox synagogues
I'm not sure why that is I don't really
have an ideological reason or
philosophical reason for that all I can
say is that if you go to Beth Jacob in
Los Angeles they actually check
everybody's bag if you bring your talus
you're it's filling which are the the
prayer the phylacteries are the parish
all with you to show they legitimately
have a security force out front that
checks your bags like you're going to
Disneyland or something okay this has
been part of Jewish reality for a very
long time does that mean that I feel
unsafe no again I walk around in public
with a yarmulke every single day every
single day America is the safest country
in world history for Jews but if you
actually want to protect Jews the answer
is not to take the guns out of the hands
of people like me or out of the hands of
people at my synagogue quarter carrying
the answer is for some of those people
to be armed so that if somebody likes
this shows up maybe it's not the
solution maybe it doesn't solve the
problem but you do have a better shot at
defending yourself if their guns in the
place so for folks who are using this as
a gun control argument I'm having a hard
time seeing that I mean California is
replete with gun control and it doesn't
actually stop shootings in California I
know because I live here
it doesn't stop anti-semitic attacks in
California I know because I live here
the attempt to jump to politics from
something that has had a long and
glorious history of thousands of years I
find deeply off-putting we ought to
delve it into the nitty gritty of
anti-semitic rhetoric and the
nitty-gritty of anti-semitic policy we
ought to delve into all of that but for
Jews Jews know that this is nothing new
not only is this nothing new this is
something that Jews have always thought
there's now on the Saturday that this
happened the Jews were reading
a section of the Bible called VA roads
from from the book of Genesis and that
sections Bible talks about Abraham's
sacrifice bicycle you know they God
tells Abraham go sacrifice your son very
cryptic section of the Bible what that
really is about what that really is
about is God saying to Abraham what are
you willing to risk are you willing to
bring your child into a more dangerous
world and stand for values even at the
risk of that child's life are you
willing to dedicate your child to me
this happened in bris Miller which is
the the circumcision ceremony for a
Jewish boy that brings him into the
Jewish world the Jewish people have
always stood up and they've said yes yes
we're willing to stand with life this is
the tree of life synagogue and willing
to stand with life and because they're
willing to stand with life there are
those who want death there are those who
want Western civilization broken down
there are those who want religion
destroyed there are people who are evil
out there the Jews have stood against
that the Jews will continue to stand
against this and if you are part of the
right side then you will stand against
it too and you'll do so without
maliciously tearing down people who are
also on the side of Western civilization
there should be more unity than
fractious nough stuff like this there
just should be okay now some things I
like and some things I hate you know
first I want to give a brief comment on
the situation in Brazil so I want to
talk about this more tomorrow because
obviously running out of time but the
situation in Brazil is that there's a
politician who is quote-unquote far
right which is to say he's a populist
his name is yeah I think it's yeah year
I'm not sure how you pronounced is it is
it year
Jair okay so send you knows bolson arrow
he won brazil's presidential election on
Sunday the reason that he won the
election is because the Communists had
been running Brazil for the past 10-15
years and they are deeply corrupt they
kept getting thrown out of office over
corruption Brazil's economy has
stagnated and so balsan are all came in
saying I'm gonna deregulate the economy
I'm gonna fight crime and they elected
him over this and people are panicking
oh it's the end of democracy in Brazil
okay we'll find out but it seems like
democracy in Brazil had some real
problems with the Communists in the very
recent past and not only that if Brazil
did not rapidly shift course on
economics and on crime the hope for the
future in Brazil was not bright it's
it's so funny how folks on the Left seem
to ignore the fact that it was left
malfeasance corruption and inability to
run a country that led to balsan arrows
win a boss in Iran said we cannot
continue flirting with communism we're
going to change the destiny of Brazil he
rejected the leftist PT that ran Brazil
for 13 of the last 15 years there were
ousted two year
years ago in the midst of a deep
recession and political graft scandal
balsa narrow won a sweeping victory who
won 55 percent of the vote that is a
very very broad victory in Brazil folks
who are panicking on you know in the
United States are panicking for the same
reason that they look at Europe and they
see right parties in Europe panicking
now let's not pretend that the Brazilian
far-right is the same thing as the
American conservative movement very few
things are the same as the limited
government american conservative
movement but balsa narrows view of
economics is much more akin to a
free-market system of economics than
anything the left was proposing and that
is one of the driving factors here
Brazil was Miss run in a in a brutal
fashion over the last 15 years the the
old joke about Brazil that was always
told as Brazil as the country of the
future and always will be well maybe if
they actually shifted economic policy
maybe if they started tamping down crime
then things would change but Brazil has
a number of its own issues that it has
to deal with and both scenarios a
symptom of those issues not the cause of
them even though the press will cover it
as though bolson arrow is the cause of
those issues okay time for a couple of
things that I like so you know the this
synagogue was called it's Who I am the
the phrase 8c I am it comes from the
book of Proverbs there is something
called dates crime in the book of
Genesis right there the tree of life in
the book of Genesis when it talks about
what's there in the garden there's the
tree of life then there's the tree of
the knowledge of good and evil Adam Eve
are allowed to eat from the tree of life
they're not allowed to eat from the tree
of knowledge of good and evil they have
to be banished from the garden so they
don't live forever after eating from the
knowledge of good evil the Jewish
tradition has always suggested the Tree
of Life is Torah it's Bible it's
relationship with God and the the
proverb you know from through proverbs
3:18 is it's claimed he lamothe cose
kimba with some cameos are so the the
that's in Hebrew the the English is that
they tree of life
you should grasp on to it because in it
you'll find pleasure that you that
you'll find happiness and it's sung
every single Sabbath and when whenever
we put away the Torah back into the our
own back into the ark we sing the song
each time he hears a choir rendition of
that song
[Music]
[Applause]
so it's you know the whole thing is just
awful and awful and awful and if we're
not all on the same side here and if we
aren't willing to call out antis emetic
rhetoric wherever it exists not for
partisan political purposes but wherever
it exists if we're not willing to stand
up against anti-semites of every brand I
don't just mean white nationalists I
mean if I'm us I mean the Palestinian
Authority I mean anti-semites who want
to destroy the State of Israel
I mean anti somebody want to see the
death of Jews everywhere if you're not
willing to do that all you see is Trump
just in big bright flashing letters when
something like this happens let me
suggest you're not being honest you're
being dishonest and you're being
spiritually dishonest as well okay time
for a couple of things that I hate as we
can see the media narrative is set here
and it's being promulgated by folks you
know who you would expect to promulgate
this media narrative last week the big
story before the shooting obviously was
this attempted bombing against a bunch
of Democratic officials Michael Moore
decided to share footage of a male
bomber at of the male bomber at a trump
rally as though this proves that
President Trump somehow deputized this
guy again the Bernie Sanders
congressional shooting had nothing to do
with Bernie Sanders it had to do with an
evil person doing an evil thing and as a
secondary note should we all take down
the rhetoric a pitch you bet we should
but this kind of stuff blaming the
entire right or President Trump for a
man sending pipe bombs in the mail is
patently and saying Bill Maher went even
further he said the president was
partnering with the bomber stream media
must clean up its act fast that sounds
like he's not condemning the bomber it
sounds to me like he's partnering with
him okay that is such a despicable
statement that when you when you
criticize the media and say that they
need to do a better job that you're
partnering with people who are sending
bombs to the media it's just it's
blatantly insane statement that's like
saying that Bill Maher is accusing
president Trump of partnering with
bomber so somebody sends if somebody
shoots President Trump because obviously
he is now complicit in terror right he's
basically a terrorist then that's Bill
Maher's fault
that's not the way it works criticizing
somebody is not the same thing as
suggesting that they ought to be killed
or that violence ought to be done
against them if that becomes the case
then free speech is really on the brink
as well so we've now so obviously
honesty is on the brink but now we've
got free speech on the brink and gun
rights on the brink everything is going
to continue getting uglier until we can
at least unify on the things we should
be
able to unify about but apparently we
can't even do that it's a very
depressing day it's been a very
depressing week hopefully the country
starts to pull out of this tailspin the
first thing to do I said this last week
with regard to the bombing I will say it
again with regard to the shooting the
first thing that we ought to be doing is
we ought to be judging people Don
Makowski loose okay we should be trying
to see people's point of view we should
try and be judging them with certain
amount of actual merit we should try to
see it as though as though they are not
bad people there are evil people and
those evil people have to be condemned
but the attempt to get people on the
back of evil people doing things that
have nothing to do with those third
parties it's just making the country a
worse place well we'll be back here
tomorrow with much more I'll be in
Vancouver so I'll be broadcasting from
there I'm speaking to a Jewish group
there we also are visiting the
University of Pittsburgh in the next few
weeks my heart goes out my prayers go
out to the folks in Pittsburgh just a
devastating devastating weekend again
and you know I hope that folks if we're
not gonna we have to cling to the tree
of life those eternal values but we also
have to cling to each other this is
still a country that was built on those
eternal values if we're not going to
cling to each other and see each other
as friends then we will surely see each
other as enemies and that the country
cannot withstand we'll be back here
tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this adventure
Pierrot show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing